focus à présent sur les maisons de
retraite le gouvernement semble avoir
tiré les leçons du premier confinement
isolement et solitude avait pu aggraver
la santé déjà fragile de certains
patients cette fois ci pas d'isolement
pour nos seniors leurs proches peuvent
continuer à leur rendre visite
exemple du côté de veigné à l'ehpad de
la croix saint paul et le chapelet enfin
en nous et on pianote en pianote c'est
l'art de la gym douce pour une partie
des 52 résidents de cet établissement
un réveil musculaire en groupe fatiha
l'animatrice donne le ton et tout le
monde s'exécute
ce genre d'animation réalisés en commun
n'avait pas été maintenu au printemps
dernier lors du premier confinement pour
éviter les contacts les résidents
étaient restées majoritairement dans
leur chambre jusqu'à la mi mai une
situation qu anne marie ne souhaite à
personne
là nous ça va parce que on est on peut
sortir quand même tout ça mais les
personnes qui sont confinés dans
l'essonne seul le poète drôle ça doit
pas être drôle
alors s'ils peuvent pas recevoir leur
famille c'est encore pire
depuis le 1er confinement les proches
des résidents ne rentre plus dans
l'établissement ni dans les chambres
deux salles ont été aménagées pour que
les familles puissent discuter en toute
sécurité des lieux qui vont donc pouvoir
continuer à accueillir du public cet
automne également c'est un soulagement
parce que ça aurait fait pour les
résidents parce que ça aurait été un
coup de massue
énormément aussi pour les familles j'ai
commencé à avoir déjà des retours de
soulagement à cette brute soulagement un
content qu'on puisse toujours revenir et
nous ça fait partie du bon équilibre
pour nos résidents à savoir les visites
et on y reste du mur c'est normal parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de musique mais on est
bilingue l'autre et ma fille a là un
match qui a eu des demandes quoi pas
d'abolition marseille tout ça quoi les
règles qui encadrent les visites ont
donc bien été intégré depuis le
printemps dernier
d'ailleurs dans cet ehpad avait nié pour
l'instant aucun résident n'a été touché
par le coronavirus